hei war wofür dieses jahr war einfach
heftig haben sich mehr leute denn je bei
mir war oh angeschaut es war spannender
denn je
es war lustiger denn je aber leider war
es auch ziemlich kurz und eine sache die
ich wirklich gehofft hatte ist leider
nicht eingetreten
ich hatte noch nie bei wago einen kill
gemacht ich hatte in meiner letzten
folge zwar recht spannenden und auch
relativ knappen kampf mit esi php
getroffen
ok ja sogar gold äpfel what the heck
also leute
es läuft nicht nach plan oh ja okay
leute das ist jetzt meine chance der
kripo könnte die begeben haben nein hat
er nicht aber leider die sie
letztendlich dann gewonnen ich habe es
aber einfach durchgezogen weil mir
persönlich daran gelegen war dass es
einfach spannend ist und bleibt aber die
ersten folgen wurden gehalt verfolgt und
dann kurz nachdem mein team partner luca
gestorben ist
ich betone ich bin tot ich bin so gut
ich betone toten nein blieb mir erst mal
nichts anderes übrig als zu versuchen
mich auszurüsten und dabei bin ich halt
ein bisschen am spor um gestritten weil
ich einfach auch gleichzeitig gehofft
habe dass ein paar leute mich finden
zwar werde ich jetzt zum sport gehen 100
prozent gibt es ja auch fallen hasborn
ich gucken ob ich noch mal meinem ein
loch finden wo ich vorhin runter
gegangen bin herr wo war das denn jetzt
ich hatte doch die mich hier einfach
irgendwo runter gebaut die change von
heute ist nicht zu fliegen
also auch wenn einer auf den server
kommt und jetzt leute wird es krass
benny und hautnah oder wie luca sagen
würde obama haben heute eine folge war
hochgeladen und ihr glaubt nicht was da
passiert ist gucken wir am besten mal
zusammenreißen und das ganze zum braten
dem so viel darf so viel gold so viel
essen also ihr habt schon gehört und
wahrscheinlich wisst ihr es auch die
buddys machen einfach extrem krasse
fallen schon die ganze zeit bei wago 4
in meinen augen haben sie auch das
projekt dadurch einfach echt bereichert
weil man hat halt nicht nur noch leute
gesehen die sich stumpf ausgerüstet
haben sondern hat auch welche gesehen
die fallen gebaut haben und ich meine
auch cool mitzufiebern auch so eine
falle dann tatsächlich aufgeht
[Musik]
okay leute darüber müssen wir reden
warum ist da dieses loch hat
irgendjemand in irgendeiner folge davor
sich direkt am zaun runter gebaut und
nicht wieder zugebaut ist irgend jemand
der das getan hat vielleicht aber ich
meine ja selbst gesehen jetzt einfach am
loch vorbei gelaufen
was ist daran jetzt so spannend oder
sowas aber wir gucken einfach noch ein
bisschen weiter
[Musik]
diese sterben war gottseidank kürzeren
und macht was du damit sich bis nach
unten kommen also sie bauen da halt
immer noch an ihrer falle extrem kreis
haben sie über mehrere folgen dran
gebaut da ich gehe 200 oben perfekt okay
das ist alles abgebaut werden
[Musik]
leute was hier
ok ich gucke direkt man die unsere gäste
rein und sagen wir nehmen alles mit was
vernichten können erwarte du hast mich
hier wieder eingebaut dass ich lieber
erde als ganz normal eigentlich haben
call wollen auf jeden fall am start sehr
cool perfektes recht für mich heute habe
ich auch im staat in der kiste zwei gaps
nimmst du dir den tag brauchen wir nicht
hier ist nämlich mit sind meine höfen
kann brauche ich jetzt eigentlich nicht
aber ich nehme ich einfach mit haben wir
neue stück springbock ich nicht das
halte ich auch nicht mehr dass hiermit
eine ganz normale folge tod nicht ernst
warum war dann noch hinter mir
was hat er gerade gesagt warum war dann
noch hinter mir
[Musik]
benny ist tut mir wirklich leid
ich meine das ist jetzt mehr oder
weniger mein erster war okay aber ich
hätte mir niemals vorgestellt dass ich
bei wo wir noch jemanden töten bzw für
den tod von jemandem verantwortlich bin
und schon gar nicht auf diese art und
weise also wirklich sie die waren halt
echt so in meinen augen favoriten so ich
meine die sind mega gut ausgerüstet die
sind die spiele auch richtig gut und
dann fällt benny einfach obwohl sie die
ganze zeit fallen machen in meinen blog
und das ist halt auch der grund bei euch
dieses video mache weil ich meine das
ist mein allererster killen war und ich
habe ihn nicht gemacht und ich war nicht
am leben ist einfach nur traurig wenn
man mal darüber nachdenkt wahrscheinlich
werden paar jetzt sagen ich habe den
könig gemacht die richtige formulierung
wäre wahrscheinlich ich habe den weg
bereitet für den tod von benny aber er
ist einfach und hereingefallen und das
ist irgendwie so ironisch weil sie die
ganze zeit fallen gebaut haben und sich
mega krass ausgerüstet haben und sondern
so ein dummkopf der einfach direkt
gestorben ist ist dann verantwortlich
für für bennys tod so oder so leute ich
kann euch nur sagen schaut euch die
ganze folge unbedingt an
bei den buggies dies mega gut also
wirklich dies richtig schön bearbeitet
wie mehr kann ich dazu nicht sagen ich
wollte halt irgendwie nicht dazu äußern
dass ich jetzt ein kill habe ihn war und
dann würde ich sagen sehen wir uns
morgen wieder sein falls ihr es noch
nicht getan habt könnt ihr euch liegen
ein video von gestern anschauen dort
habe ich bin gesprengt dann würde ich
sagen sehen wir uns morgen wieder und
bis dahin und noch mal dicke story an
benny ich hab's nicht gewollt aber
irgendwie habe ich jetzt hat auch ein
war okay ich weiß nicht so recht
macht's gut